office seeing a lot more cases of
ringworm
we've seen more cases in the last month
and a half
than i think i've seen in a long time
by the way it is very contagious says dr
jamie augustine of oasis animal hospital
it's actually a fungus that causes a
circular rash shaped like a ring and
it's kind of red and itchy there's no
worms involved even though the names
kind of eludes that it might the fungus
that causes the infection can live on
your skin surfaces be found in the dirt
so dogs cats cows goats pigs horses and
they can all spread a ring worm to
people and then people can also pass it
on to animals
fairly easy to treat
if you have a single lesion on an animal
you can treat with a topical medication
you may need a shampoo if you get more
than a couple of them you may need oral
medication
all right so if you're wondering if your
pet might have ring worm it creates a
patch as you heard there but of hair
loss and then also the skin might get
kind of crusty so in addition to
medication you'll need to deep clean and
sterilize your home because it is very
very contagious